hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 4 of
book 3 of Epictetus discourses we're
treated to a rather funny and that's
ironic here a little bit rather funny
exchange between Epictetus and authority
figure an official who goes to the the
theater and favors one of the actors
that the crowd doesn't really like so
much and he pulls rank to get you know a
prize given to that particular actor the
crowd doesn't like it and as it says in
the translation they revile him now in
the Greek it's actually learn grow some
classes is the participle that's being
used to discuss them so we might
translate that a little bit more
colloquially as talking trash about him
they get on his case they you know give
him the Bronx raspberry you know
whatever they're conveying a kind of
attitude of didn't perhaps discuss or
aggression or you know criticism and
they're doing it as much as they can
they know that they can only go so far
with it because he's actually an
authority figure right so he's not happy
this and he goes to Epictetus and says
you know what should I make of this so
here's what Epictetus tells him and he
has a great implications for those who
are in authority in gem so this is apply
to people who are you know managers who
are you know professors for example in
relation to students professors can
often make students do things that the
students aren't really happy about it
would apply to people in families where
one person is kind of first among equals
or perhaps not even among equals they
think they they rule the roost really
any time where you've got a position of
superiority with one person or several
people being on top and then inferiority
with other people you know the majority
being on the bottom this sort of dynamic
would apply so epic tina says those who
are in positions of authority they set
an example they set the expectations for
other people who are under them who are
in their authority right and a big
question there is then what kind of
example are they set ideally from a snow
in perspective they would be keeping
their faculty of choice in accordance
with nature right that that's a good for
the stoics that's the ideal that one is
aiming at that involves keeping oneself
out of things that aren't really one's
own business so if you go to the movie
theater you don't need to be talking
trash about the movie while other people
are trying to watch the movie you know
you don't need to certainly wouldn't be
like throwing things from the back row
like like kids do or I used to at that
time you would try to behave in a
courteous way towards other people
because that's what act in accordance
with nature demands in that sort of
situation you would be taking care not
to get yourself involved in vain
struggles and disputes that don't get it
that's not what this guy does as a
matter of fact let me read the story a
little bit so
the procurator of a purist took the sign
of a comic actor and somewhat
undignified a cosmos manner and was
reviled by the people for doing so so
that he brought word to Epictetus and he
gave expression to his indignation the
word there's an ignominious two toasts
meaning he was angry right he got upset
and then the men who had reviled him and
then I big penises well what were they
doing these who were taking sides just
as you yourself had you set an example
they followed your exam says when the
other ask is that the way to that in
which a man take sides you replied yes
they saw you there governor the friend
and procure owner of seeds are taking
sides in that way were they likely to
take sides in the same way it is you're
an authority Epictetus is saying you
have a moral responsibility to set a
good example and you don't get to be
angry with other people if they don't
follow you know the example that you're
saying you want them to follow but
they're actually following the example
that you're giving it's your own fault
it comes back as we say to bite you for
behaving that way I will talk about some
examples in just a moment besides this
so getting involved what he did is he
got involved in something that is not
his own business that's what epictetus
is going to say a little bit later you
wanted so and so to get the crown they
wanted the other guy to get it he says
upon entering the theater we should say
should we say let's see that sophron
gets a crown and not rather let me in
this subject matter maintain my moral
purpose in accordance with nature no one
is dearer to me them to myself it's
absurd for me to let myself be heard in
order that another man may win a victory
as a calm
character it's it's a dumb move for this
guy to get so invested in making sure
that his candidate is going to win when
he gets nothing out of it nothing
valuable even though he was going to get
like some money out of it or a
connection or some sort of you know
pleasure that's not really that
important that's that's not enough to
justify getting embroiled in something
that's not one's own affair not up to
oneself right now here's where it pans
out is it in terms of the authority he
set an example of a kind of behavior
imprudent behavior a thoughtless
behavior right if he'd wanted the people
to act in a good way he should have
acted in a good way instead he gives
them a bad example so you know he
doesn't really have any grounds as epic
you this is going to say for being angry
with them they're just doing what
they're going to naturally do which is
this guy is doing yeah I'm going to do
the same thing as him he's going to take
signs whoa why shouldn't I take sides
right the authority figure himself is
doing it why can't the rest of us do it
just because he won't let us well then
he's being unfair and then like
Epictetus says they act out of warded
self-interest you're going to act out of
self-interest and get it play favorites
they're going to act out of
self-interest to because they're seeing
you do it but you're not going to let
them and so he will say to this guy here
we go what people should not take sides
in this way you'd better not do it
yourself but if they should why are you
angry if they imitated for you for who
do they have to imitate but you their
superior whom did they look too but you
when they go to the theaters see one of
them says see how that guy acts the
theater he's shot very well oh all shout
too he jumps up and down I'll jump up
and down to his group of sleigh
different parts of the house and shout I
don't have any slaves all shout as loud
as I can to make up for all of them they
says you ought to know that when you
enter the theater you enter as a
standard of behavior and this is an
example to the rest showing them how
they want to act in the theater why then
did they revile you every man hates what
gets in his way this is a basic part
about the self interesting so if you're
going to more other people's self
interest you're going to you know use
your authority or your power or your
rank to not allow them to do what they
want to do when you're doing what you
want to do don't be surprised when they
have some bad stuff to say about you
right he says they wanted so and so to
get the crowd you want the other head
kid they were standing in your way you
and there's you turned out to be the
stronger and didn't want you what they
they did what they could and revival was
standing in their way what that do you
what you wish that you should be able to
do as it here if you want to be able to
do what you want but they don't get to
do what they want because you don't want
them to do so your desires fought to be
acted on but nobody else gets to act on
their desires as a matter of fact they
meant they've got to keep their actions
such that you can't even tell that they
want something different or you'll get
upset with them how irrational is that
Epictetus is same to this guy you know
he says you were able to do it you wish
but you should they should not even say
what they wish how crazy is that to
expect them now this has implications
far outside of some ancient quarrel in
thesis about a local official in a
theater think about how this this
affects the classroom think about how
this affects the restaurant you know
where the owner or the Executive Chef or
the manager sets a bad example for for
the employees think about how this works
in the corporate boardroom or you know
in the
factory think about how this works
within the family where parents are
telling children they have to behave in
a certain way the parents themselves are
not setting a good example and are
cracking down on the kids for doing
exactly what the parents are going to do
a great example of that if you don't
want your kids to smoke or drink or
something like that maybe don't do it
right in front of them and then tell
them they don't get to do it you know if
you want them to show up on time well
then you could make sure that you show
up on time consistently right because
otherwise you're being like this procure
honor Procurator who you know is
engaging in behavior that he's not
letting other people do he's being kind
of a tyrant Disney and people don't like
that so they're going to say bad stuff
about that and it's irrational for him
to be upset as a matter of fact
epictetus is trying to get him to see
the mistake that he himself is making so
this applies to pretty much anybody
who's in authority over other people and
their function of setting an example